hey Gamers sorry I've been quiet for the
last two days I've been thinking of how
I should respond to the allegations that
I don't love my fans my knee-jerk
response is this is dumb of course I
love you all you make my life worth
living but when those DMS leaked where I
said I hate my fans they are all stupid
little sheep point I was devastated I
wrote that in a moment of weakness I was
also intoxicated on adult beverages and
for those angry that I got the wrong
sound for sheep you are justified in
your anger I know that oink is for
Piggies which you are also not Piggies I
mean anyways I have a new merch drop can
you make both sections of the poll even
good luck evil face